the man to my right season 2 of SWAT
premiering tomorrow night Thursday on
CBS at 10:00 Eastern Time loved his work
for all those years in Criminal Minds in
a fabulous alum of The Young and the
Restless you know that shemar Moore good
to see you serious so how many athletes
did you find out watch soap operas when
you wrong it was crazy I mean I got into
the game and you know and I I knew about
soap operas in high school just cuz the
girlfriends they would run home at lunch
and watch sunset beach in Santa Barbara
and all those shows and I wasn't really
into the soaps but you know as a
teenager he followed the girls around
then I get on a soap and I'm in a club
in LA I'm probably 24 25 years old and
Deion Sanders is there Cal Ripken
juniors there they having some sport and
end and I'm walking by and who was
Michael Irvin and so I'm walking by and
and I'm a starstruck I'm starstruck in
this club with like all these major you
mean legends just stand-in there and I'm
walking by trying to like mind my own
business because like I'm just not near
as cool as these athletes and I wasn't
but I just saw I'm just kind of skirting
by and win and Dionne goes yo B yo
that's Malcolm that's Malcolm from the
stories that's mountain from the stories
that Michael Irvin was like yeah it is
hey come here dog come here dog and
you'd be messing with that drusilla
you'd be messing with that fine-ass
Drusilla and and and I'm sitting there
like looking like is this really
happening and they were on me like y'all
you are the you are the man what's it
like to work with her you mean oh no
you'd be doing kissing scenes with
Drusilla I was like y'all watch young
and the restless' they're like y'all man
when we know hotel that's all we do man
right after practice we watch the
stories and I was just like buggin out
and then through the years of just more
and more Meryl Streep watches Criminal
Minds
The Wrestler actor on the run on half
weeks Mickey Rourke I'll make you open
watch the soap P watch come on yeah so I
mean just but it was just nuts to me
that these athletes were like stuck on
stupid when it came to story the number
of times that things happen in
goom's clubhouses in the nfl's like it's
like a soap opera and you're wondering
where these guys pick it up from they
watch actual Yelp oh yes
oh yeah the certain baseball players in
particular yeah cuz they're on the road
three games ends wake up in the hotel
room 11:00 a.m. 12:00 o'clock one
o'clock whatever I got a blog kind of
email thing back in the day before the
social media from Cal Ripken jr. I'm a
just because he watches young and
restless and he has a crush on Phyllis
or somebody so I know you're from the
Oakland area yeah no can we talked about
this before and when you came on the
last time are you concerned at all with
the outset of the NBA season coming that
somebody's coming
for the crown what's the I fight with my
family all the time I'm half black half
white the black side of me is Oakland
and the white side of me is Boston so
born in Oakland I grew up Ricky Anderson
fan Oakland A's but then I had to pick
between the A's the Raiders the Niners
and the Giants I was at battle of the
bay when the earthquake hit so I've got
my family in Boston is all about
Patriots it's Tom Brady everything
Celtics all that other stuff so the
splash brothers are here now and you
know the KD the whole crew I mean klay
Thompson Steph you know dream on killing
the game killing the game but the
Celtics are coming the Celtics are
coming and my family keeps reminding me
that they're coming because they would
they would they would deep they've a
decent last year they were just too
young and inexperienced to take it the
rest of the way so and injured too you
know and injured too you know with so
and I know you're talking his language
over there that's a big time Celtic fan
yeah yeah the only thing about the
Warriors is you know when you win a lot
you get a little complacent you know you
start you know you just you got the
money you got the rings you get a little
comfortable you know you don't work
quite as hard as you used to i mean you
know nothing lasts forever but i think i
think that if they if they stay focused
they got a good three four years now the
team dominating the team that has beaten
okay the warriors during this stretch
the cleveland cavaliers right had a
certain player that now resides here in
Los Angeles
fornia and one would think that even
though there is no Kevin Love stature
player that's here in Los Angeles were
in the Laker purple and gold right now
there are a whole bunch of young players
and former Celtic champion rage on Rondo
that's here in Los Angeles that maybe
LeBron with this roster can come at the
I think I think if LeBron does what
LeBron seems to be able to do he'll get
him to the playoffs and in your first
year he'll get him to the playoffs I'd
have some young talent there hungry he's
gonna be a leader or mentor but in my
opinion I think they're one superstar
away so I think you know maybe next
season they just got to bring in one
more boss and you know a big man in the
middle so the Brahmin can do his thing
they need one more boss but Dido I just
don't I think the Celtics are gonna
school I think I think my warriors are
gonna school the only thing I'm worried
about with LeBron is is between LeBron
and the two football teams the traffic
is gonna be a nightmare man LeBron's
playing I'm staying on I'm not getting
on them streets certainly but I'm
definitely gonna go watch the boy play
certain like the Dodgers make the World
Series too but my red socks my red socks
though see see I told you I'm in Oakland
dude but it's it's it's Warriors
basketball its Niners football for me
okay and it's Boston Red Sox baseball so
I'm all over the place because a family
dynamic and how its raised but the
Giants I mean when the bonds era that
didn't capture you the reason I love the
Giants like I said I was at Battle of
the bay for the World Series when they
had that earthquake when I was in junior
high school I worked for the San
Francisco Chronicle as a paperboy and on
my route was Bill Walsh coach of the
Niners come on and Willie Mays so there
you go so I had to love them all and not
say this is funny Christmas Christmas
would come by you know throw the papers
or you throw the papers or you
but both both Bill Walsh and Willie Mays
sent their wives out to tell me come to
the door on Christmas when I delivered
the paper and this is back when Bill
Walsh was doing all those Volvo
commercials and so Bill Walsh would give
me a $50 crisp bill he'd hand it to me
and said thanks for doing a good job
then I'd go over to say Hayes house
mazes house yes he gave me a
hundred-dollar bill and a sign bat from
Hank Aaron not himself what he gave me I
have it in my office well I have a
signed bat from Hank Aaron and Willie
would give me a crisp hundred-dollar
bill Greaves paper out everything right
right are they in my paper their paper
was never late
that's it never late when you threw the
paper it Willie Mae's house did you ever
come out and catch it over the show no
he did you know he didn't but I always
put I put bill Walsh's paper right on
top of his Volvo the one I thought he
was driving so he'd get it and I I mean
I neatly placed Willie's paper right at
his front door the rest of my threw him
in the bushes and did you ever jamar
more of Swat here
season 2 of Swat premiering tomorrow
night Thursday on CBS did you ever try
to play sports yeah no I played sports
my whole life I got I got drafted by
Boston and Baltimore coming out of high
school from actually baseball baseball I
was I was a pitcher in an outfielder and
so I threw about 95 coming out of high
school but my mother could you write
there was shed a picture yeah yeah look
at a jheri curl look Jerry that was my
little peach fuzz you couldn't tell me
nothing because the rest of it wouldn't
grow but ya know I played baseball
football ran track but my game was
baseball my uncle my uncle Steven Wilson
out in Boston he played semi-pro
baseball out in Boston and he put me on
my first little league team and then he
caught me in a rock fight in second
grade
there's a little racial tension going on
in Boston at the time and some white
kids were you know throwing rocks at me
and I decided to throw rocks back and my
uncle taught at the the high school and
the the principal or whoever called him
and said they'd come get your nephew and
he came to the parking lot and saw me
throwing rocks back at the other kids
now he knew that he needed to stop me
because that was the wrong thing to do
let's stop this but before he says
before he had to stop for a minute and
watching me throw these rocks because I
was winging them and he realized that I
had a really good arm and so he stopped
me from the rock fight and then put me
on a baseball team and then fast forward
I just kept playing kept playing figured
it out got pretty good at it got a I got
a scholarship to Santa Clara University
played four years of varsity
and my dream was to play in Fenway Park
and make my uncle proud didn't quite
work out for me but I did get close as
far as Fenway in Oh seven I threw out
the first pitch in Fenway Park and I was
too nervous to lob it so I just I just
unloaded and they told me I had threw it
about 81 miles an hour who caught it do
you remember Varitek so one day he'd be
gone and he caught one of those late
over the shoulder yeah Varitek caught
you it wasn't a strike it wasn't a spicy
no but he just he just he's a big boy so
he he just did one of these but cuz I
just got up to I was so nervous I mean
it was worse than any audition or any
girl you're trying to meet I was like I
couldn't feel my body and and I'm
standing on the mound and because I'm an
actor I started trying to play to the
crowd I'm standing there and we're
playing the Tampa Tampa Bay Devil Rays
and and so I start patting my chest like
to tell the tell the crowd I'm nervous
and then true Boston fashion somebody
from the first base first base stands
goes already and vertex couldn't even
frame it huh it is okay i frame it or
not a picture of you look at you look
that is focused you are locked yeah
that's pure fear right there look at
that man and my uncle says to me before
I walked out to the field now your uncle
dis my uncle put me on my first baseball
team a schoolteacher works at the post
office
ex-marine was in Vietnam all he's
supposed to tell me is good luck have
some fun that's what that's what I want
to hear yeah he looks at me before I
walk out to the mound and they're giving
me this introduction ladies and
gentlemen coming to the mound from
Criminal Minds used to play varsity
baseball into 94 miles an hour in
college right and I'm like Nana and I
see myself in the big screen and I'm
wetting my pants and I look at my uncle
for one last piece of confidence and he
goes don't you balance it
[Laughter]
before you go I want to play a little
bit of celebrity true or false with you
here if you don't mind some of your own
your your IMDB bio information or on
Wikipedia let's do it with Jamar my wife
SWOT here before you send him on his way
your first on-screen credit was John
Mark on the TV series living single in
1995 is that true or false
my first on TV credit yeah it's true but
not my first so it's false okay so what
was your first young and restless young
Restless was four that was my first
professional debut as a professional
actor okay so then living single was it
like being on that I you know what I was
I it was fun and I was it's great show
is a great group of people but I had
never done comedy so it was so out of my
comfort zone so and my acting coach who
still my acting coach to this day I
called him in between rehearsals and I
was like I don't know if I can do this I
don't know because I wasn't quite secure
with comedic timing and all that yes and
they had me play you know I was the
good-looking guy who was coming to one
of the actresses and take her on a date
and you know and it it was it was so it
was fun but I was still very early in my
career it end and I was comfortable that
young and restless because that became
my comfort zone I knew everybody but now
is around a new group of people that
were all about comedy so it really
scared the mess out of me and so I had
to just get through it but it inspired
me I was like okay that was scary but so
now I know what I need to work on so now
now you know I'm a big silly do
different my fans who've watched me on
my social media you know I'm nobody
stand-up comedian I'm not Kevin Hart
Jamie Foxx I mean that's those guys
dance to a different drum but you know
I've come a long way as far as what I
know how to do so if I got a chance to
do a living single s-type show I'd be
right then you do it once again yeah
next one up your nickname in high school
was curls for girls is that a true story
I used to say I got the curls for the
girls
yeah and though I had a bunch of
nicknames my name is Shamar so I
challenged people to come up with a
nickname that I haven't had and so I've
had right now my homies call me sham
they're like what a big sham but I've
been sham I've been shamrock
I've been sham Ron shimmy shimmy Coco
Puffs
Ashlin meals schlemazel sham boogie the
picture you showed me payment what so it
was it was the jheri curl so you go to
Longs Drugs and you know I cuz I had
that you know I cut it into the shag
basically basically it's the black guy's
version of the white guy's mullet all
right so I had I had the hair and you go
to Longs Drugs and you get this yellow
and red bottle of what's called curl
activator goop that up and put that and
put that in your activated and right and
then like Soul glow from Eddie Murphy
and so I used to walk around going yeah
see you see it I got the curls for the
girls and last one for you here you were
the presenter when Susan Lucci finally
won her Daytime Emmy are very true very
true and I almost cussed on national
television because I was on I was on the
red carpet doing interviews and
everybody was like so was the street
gonna be over it honey how do you feel
about her Street cuz she had been
nominated like I don't know 19 times or
something and never won so I kept
hearing about the street me hearing
about the streak and I knew I was doing
that catagory and I did a couple
interviews then we go inside and I'm
sitting down there okay mr. Moore we
need you backstage cuz we got you got to
do your category and nobody thought she
was gonna win there just cuz she hadn't
won right not because she didn't deserve
it she just hasn't won and so I get out
there and you know they give you the
card and I didn't know and so I'm like
you know I'm reading the teleprompter
and so then it's time to open and the
winner is can I literally flip the card
and there was a favorite there was
another woman who was so we thought was
gonna win the con and I know I almost
almost went holy and I think I was in
and then I just caught myself and with
the streak is over Susan Lucci and the
place went nuts and I think she got like
a three and a half minute standing
ovation she walked up and so you almost
had your own lala land yeah a bit little
bit 8 Congrats on season 2 a SWAT thank
you man a blast doing it yeah that's a
good time it's a good time check us out
yeah check you out
Thursday nights on CBS the man who plays
Hondo Harrelson himself for the TV
audience stay right there because this
man apparently does his own 40-yard dash
run and when it when the chips are down
that's coming out the next year shemar
Moore thanks for coming on they say
follow him much at Shamar more on
Twitter the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience